champions chester is as i said the first
full season of online chess we will have
10 tournaments in 10 months we will have
one overall winner
one full season of top class chess to
find the undisputed greatest online
chess player on the planet each side
will have 15 minutes for the whole game
they will gain 10 seconds after every
move when it gets down to the last
couple of minutes there'll be lots of
nerves in the knockout stages there will
be blitz in armageddon when time will be
slashed things will be even more
exciting will we actually see players
losing on time here
yes absolutely it's going to be
guaranteed we're going to see panic on a
scale we've never seen before
[Music]
he just tricked oh
[Music]
why is magnus crossing having a huge
laughter
he's turning dubose to philosophy
against himself remember duval famously
said when my pieces are attacked i
counter attack magnet magnus has
attacked the queen
and it says that it's how do they okay
you can see it chess is uh funny
the computers haven't killed chess
look at nepal story david but just that
it's so funny i think it's kind of fly
or something um i mean he's not just
being bothered by wesley he's been
bothered by the fly important way to
break open the position um we talked
about this
no look at that oh is that a cat yeah i
didn't even know he had it he suddenly
just jumped on his chair punching
poncho has he been there with you the
whole day today lavon yes of course he's
looking for his daddy now you have your
own mascots
[Music]
in 20 seconds by giving another check
with his bishop instead he does take
that black knight all you need to do now
is stop that black pawn and levon
aronian is going to win this game and he
has doing that
levon he's one bishop up now he should
not let this chance slip black's king
almost about to get checkmated anyway
magnus just resigns he resigns wow what
a dramatic final game between these two
only one move
delivers the knockout okay
it's actually checkmate next move wow
and that means uh the balleronian he's
the winner of this game bishop comes in
right in and
the knight is going to be lost
there is just nothing that artemia can
do
runny winds look at that the vulneran
with his hands in the air he is the
winner of the gold money asian rapid
after a dominant performance the great
levon aronian
[Music]
[Applause]
why ever takes that rope black queens
with check
that rook it's a kamikaze roof it's just
trying to it's suicidal it's trying to
give itself up it's trying to it's
trying to die but uh white is not taking
that rook yet at some point you'll have
to though yeah exactly desperate times
call for desperate measures 12 year old
avi manu mishra he's number 612 in the
world he's beating number 21 penta
lahari krishna wow and we can see it on
magnus now he realizes he blundered yeah
total blunder
and actually we had this scenario
yesterday with magnus his king being
attacked by a queen and a rook the black
king is not safe magnus castle also only
with 20 seconds
and that's it oh look at daniel dubo
his hands in the air he has beaten the
world champion after three games in the
second quarter final match
dude are trying one final trick he gives
up his rook he's hoping for some
stalemate ideas but look at that
celebration from raj above what a
performance bye team or rajabov i'm also
sorry i mean there is an arbiter at john
i mean he was here for last i don't know
okay yeah he was here for last i don't
know ten days or something or maybe
eight or something
changing yeah but i mean at some point i
think yesterday he said that the games
are boring so i can just you know
subsequently play some some exciting
chess
[Music]
white has no way to break through 26
seconds it should be enough for rajabov
oh okay and uh that's it for the draw of
vegetable for spirit and timor rajavo is
the winner of the quarter final match
against janupo
mike is threatening to check the white
king and the steward oh is he smiling
did you see that yeah the game's still
going but he's already celebrating
the reason he celebrated his he knows
the minimum he'll get now is a draw
he does look invincible right now and
there we see it the game will end in a
draw and it is and there we go
again
celebrating oh look how happy he is he
is the winner of the air things master
at 33 years old timora jabo has made a
fantastic comeback
in the last game of today and
[Music]
david
[Laughter]
this is always this is what i always
dreamed of when i first took up chess
it's like the next big thing kaya
we cool
i mean i can't even move the mouse
anymore
[Laughter]
what and my nose goes
[Music]
[Applause]
there have been so many draws uh
with this queen
queen d
e4 d4 queen e66 in the berlin so i
thought i'd show people that there are
other ways to
repeat as well
wow i think yeah napoleon actually
looked away because i don't know whether
he's laundered this last move but and
he's going
he's won the tournament anish giri is
the winner of the magnus crossing
invitational huge congratulations i mean
obviously it's good it's great to win
[Music]
that's a huge blunder by wesley so he
magnus castle can win the game
immediately well he's going to see this
move i
i'm sure of it if he finds knight takes
pawn he's going
he hasn't done it whoa
look at the bar why does it completely
shift sides here uh black simply traded
off his best piece at this person
it's the ghost of that first game where
he sacrificed in the backfire
whoa the bar is completely shifting
sides here now yeah i think magnus
carson has just lost the thread over the
last couple of moves he should have been
activating pieces but instead he
activated pawns it doesn't look like
he's just missed the key moments he's
taken his foot off the pedal and
suddenly in the current position wesley
so he's defending everything wesley
makes the draw wesley though is the
winner of the oprah euro rapid game big
it's big it's totally unexpected
to beat magnus in any match it's a huge
honor
[Music]
after nine tournaments 81 days of chess
a total of
1596 games with 44 different players we
have made it to the big tour finals you
guys but it is going to be a total of 10
players ready to fight for the ultimate
prize to be named the overall winner of
the meltdown champions chess store 2021
i am so excited we're finally here it's
the moment we've all been waiting for
the end of a huge really successful tour
i think there's gonna be a lot of
insight excitement there's gonna be
intense moments you have those at the
top of the table who will be feeling the
heat to win those points and those at
the bottom who quite frankly can just
sit there and enjoy themselves and play
the role of spoiler
[Music]
now this is the second time we've seen
this position and duda just allows the
draw he doesn't even try to keep the
game going magnus carlsen wins today's
match
[Music]
oh my god magnus carlsen has just given
up his queen what
he's going to get three pieces in return
but look at this black knight i said it
was pinned it cannot move it stepped
back capturing a bishop and then white
bishop took a queen right now it's a
crazy imbalance white has a queen black
has a knight and two bishops in return
that's just look how
this is just an exercise in dominance
now it's a queen on the board and that's
it game over
magnus carlsen wins the first hybrid
game and okay
okay so
you re-take some action and look at this
from nakamura a massive blunder
artemia has everything perfectly on the
control he's better than them blunders
in one move
with the rookie for finna fade
this is tajiki look at the white king
it's just too weak it's
defenseless
and
firstly so leaning back easy getting
ready to resign there we go it is a draw
levon takes the draw and seals today's
match
congratulations to magnus carlsen he is
the winner of the mouthwater champions
chess tour 2021
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you